Intellectually,
I understand that all of us are going to
die,
that humanity will perish and fall back
into perfect obscurity,
maybe not tomorrow or for a million
years,
but eventually all we ever made will be
dust,
and yet I keep making things other than
for the reason that existential dread
grips may only about once a week and
that I have a concern for bettering my
world along more modest timescales.
I make things because those things have
intrinsic value.
To me,
that's not a simple concept,
intrinsic value,
and yet it's something we all have
assigned to the things we love to do.
It's why we love to do them because that
activity is valuable for its own sake.
Writing Fiction,
that's something I do for its own sake.
Making music.
This channel,
the nerdwriter is intrinsically valuable
to me.
It combines my love of learning and
expression with the skills I've gained
in video editing over years and years.
When I'm editing these blogs,
a process that takes about four to six
hours,
I often find myself in a sort of super
focused state where it almost seems like
my awareness is merging with my actions
on the computer and the next thing I
know I'm feeling lightheaded because
hours have passed and I've completely
forgot to eat dinner and now it's 1:00
AM.
There's a psychological term for this
feeling and it's called flow.
It's a concept introduced by a Hungarian
psychology professor.
Mihai cheeks sent me high when he became
fascinated by how artists got lost in
their work.
When she accidentally I talked to
painters or athletes or scientists.
They all described to him similar
feelings of heightened focus.
One composer described it like this.
You are in an ecstatic state to such a
point that you feel as though you almost
don't exist.
My hand seems devoid of myself and I
have nothing to do with what is
happening.
I just sit there in a state of awe and
wonderment and the music just flows out
of.
It was this continual reference to the
image of being in a river or water
flowing that gave Mei the name for his
phenomenon and it seems about as old as
humanity is.
The historical sources suggests that
Michelangelo may have been in a state of
flow while painting the Sistine Chapel.
It's reported that he would paint for
days at a time forsaking food or sleep
in the Tao of Jeet Kune Doe.
Bruce Lee instructs empty your mind,
be formless,
shapeless,
like water.
Everyone can experience this feeling,
but to do so requires a few
preconditions.
First,
you have to be involved in an activity
with a clear set of goals and progress.
The task at hand must have clear and
immediate feedback and most importantly,
there has to be a good balance between
the perceived challenges of a task and
one's perceived skill.
She sent me high,
developed a model for his idea and it
looks like this.
On the y axis is the challenge level,
and on the x axis is the skill level.
As you can see,
when the challenge really hard and the
skills are really low,
that's going to cause anxiety because
you know what you want to do,
but you can't even get close to
achieving any kind of representative
drawing fits that category for me only
when the challenge level is high and you
have the skills to match kind of state
of flow be achieved.
The composer I quoted above had been
working at is crap for decades.
The process was second nature to him.
A pro athlete who gets in the zone,
another synonym for flow practices for
the balance of his life.
I've been video editing for 10 years and
because of all those years of hard
earned technique,
I can see what I want to do,
like a mechanic can see how the pieces
of a car should come together and like a
mechanic or a composer or an athlete.
I'm forced to push myself into new
territory because the challenges
eventually get easier and I fall back
into a state of control.
When writing fiction,
I waver somewhere between arousal and
anxiety.
It will be many more years.
I suspect before my talent matches the
Gargantuan task of writing and I can
slip into that space where the muteness
nest of my thoughts resolves into the
lovely shapes I admire in other writers.
The key point here is that flow is
possible in so many areas of experience.
Art,
science,
sports at work,
in business or law or medicine,
but it's vital.
Prerequisite in all those cases is an
extended devotion to crap.
We all have the ability to distinguish
between different qualities of pleasure
being in a flow state seems to me to be
made of pure stuff,
not just for what it achieves,
but for what it is.
I don't know why human beings can
experience intrinsic value in the
activities that they choose to love,
but I'm happy to go along for the ride.
So since I've been back from my last
little break,
we've talked about beach whales,
Comic Book Films,
Keen Sugi,
the hero effect,
how nuclear weapons screwed art forgers
video games,
architecture of the right to be
forgotten and now flow and the
conversations and discussions in the
weeks following all those videos have
been more interesting to me in most
cases.
Then the videos themselves.
I want to thank everybody who's been
watching since I've been back and
engaging in these videos and these
topics.
I'm glad you're part of this community.
If you're watching this,
thank you for watching and engaging and
continue to do so.
I'm going to focus as much as I can on
you asked me anything on tumbler where
we can really sort of expand on these
topics or comment below.
Post this on reddit.
Follow me on twitter for short little
thoughts,
all that good stuff.
I will see you next Friday.